So, what is it like to be part of such a large ensemble and getting together
Large ensemble
It's great coming into it seeing this whole family just interact with each other and
When they were very welcoming for me, so that was that was quite nice. Yeah
Chrissy all right
You know what signing up to a movie like this one, you know, you have to make you know
Consider you have to keep coming back
You don't really know what you're signing up for so you don't know everybody involved yet and and to kind of be dealt this
lucky hand of everyone's being just jams is
Really just an embarrassment of riches. You've been a part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe for a long time and
Your fan experience. Do you have a good experience with the fans that you've
Truly been it's it's been the thing that makes this. I mean this sounds cheesy that makes this all worth it
you know when you when you're making these movies you have them in mind because you know how much it means to them because I
know how much movies meant to me when I was younger, especially things that involve trilogies and
The the Mark said earlier the dedication that's really like the best word to describe it
they're they're so committed and
it's it's this kind of
built in anticipation and built-in hype and and it's it makes
every day on set exciting because if you're excited about something they're gonna be excited about something and that that that's what makes this so
Satisfying you can't walk around
Feeling bad for very long when someone's like runs up. Oh my god
So you played Bruce Banner over and I did a few that over and over about two
I
Mean obviously is a very complex guy. He he's you know
if going back to to these backstory and all the in the comics, he's you know, he's got a heavy
he comes from a heavy background and uh
You know, he's got it he's got to work it out
He has to really work it out and he does, you know
He he he gets to where he needs to be
Marked
Yeah similar character
Sorry, um my favorite part playing nebula, and I think it's just sort of trying to make this villain
Empathetic and trying to I basically sort of feel like her lawyer where I'm like, no she was totally justified
Here's why I've been hopefully trying to get the audience to sort of and
Understand her a little bit more and I think that's probably a good message for the world tried to understand your enemies, you know
So you play Thor over the Cinematic Universe many many times what was exciting about playing this version the floor in endgame?
well
It was each time
I've always wanted to do something different and thor ragnarok was for me the biggest sort of shift tunnel II and I came into
Infinity Ward and he was talking to you know, the directors and said look
I really want to continue with this newer version I've created and they said no. No, we've got any new aversion and
That was what I've really appreciated in
Infinity war and in this one again and I wish I can tell you about what that is. No, it's some super cool stuff
I can't wait for people to see other stuff
And Captain Marvel just made her debut and made her mark in the Cinematic Universe. How was it to be playing with the Avengers? I?
Don't know who
Don't even know what my point is in this movie at all. I might just stop in for a quick set. I'm gonna leave
Understand
When you pause over to the trailer
That's right. That's in the trailer. Of course
That you said that was your hard-luck. You did say the highlight
I felt like it was difficult
That day, I know just like relax. So I'm just a world. It's just Chris. It's just Chris. I'm just someone destroy
This was like I think of it as some time when I was like getting, you know all around just trying to get sea legs
and
Done. You've been in the Marvel Cinematic Universe. A--'s for a long time. What is your favorite part about playing war machine?
Oh, I just say legs
Why did you do that before my question?
Tired team me up for something
no, this has been a very interesting ride and a lot of fun and a lot of growth that these characters have and and and
Still to be this many movies in and to still be changing. They still have new stuff to do. It's just been really exciting
So both of your characters were off doing other things during infinity Wars
So how does it feel to be back in the fight? We don't fight we get along famously
In fact, the reason we weren't even in and we went on we went we went on a ping-pong tour across your us
Right. We were visiting France. Yeah, we had swim lessons together, right? It was a really great time
It was a fun summer. And then we got back and found out everything that had happened
That's right
Thankfully we avoided it. That's right
Well, okay Jeremy your character Hawkeye has a close relationship with Black Widow
How did it feel as an actor to get back in the groove with working with Scarlett?
Hey with I anything expended with everybody the best part of this this movie is because I've been with every woman for so long
It's it's it's all pretty much like family. So
I'm you know, it's it's the best part of the movie every thought ant-man and with the Avengers in civil wars
So yeah, how was it for you? I was especially nice for me because it was you know was a little bit like
seeing some friends that I met once long ago and hadn't seen in a while and I got to come back and hang out and
It was it was amazing. I mean, it's really it's it's a fun thing to work on something that is so kind of
Global and has such interest but it's made better by the fact that everybody is really cool
It was nice to hang out with with everybody and go to dinner. There's some dinners
What an amazing thing to be a part of the tone on the set. This film has a different tone
How was it working in the fatone?
Who told was it was like a b-flat? I think so. Yeah, it's like a b-flat, which I always I
Always think that's the nicest tell ya and it's one that's really not used very much
Agreed agreed
Working with the Russo brothers. Yes. Tell us about what they're amazing man. They're awesome. Yeah. I wish I could do more with them
They're so busy now. But yeah, they're it's
wonderfully collaborative, you know and super smart and
Maybe weird kind of just having one of them around, you know, right? I know they do
You know
They they work in the way that I guess siblings who have grown up and have been interested in the same thing their whole lives
They it's like they do share a brain and you know, they're both kind of in control of everything that's going on and everything
That's going on is so massive. It's still kind of shocking to me that they're
They've got it all going on
Yeah, rounds they can see it all you know, they're really impressive and for each of you personally
What was the highway what has been your highlight of your experience so far in the Marvel Cinematic Universe?
It's been what's been the highlight highlight for you this
moment right now
Really not not sitting for you. You're pretty amazing and all but I think it's
To determine to this I didn't know this was happening what was going on?
it's it's kind of only now you can kind of look back and reflect upon the last decade of
all the movies and I got a people be a part of a lot of those which is pretty awesome and
So I'm very excited to see this movie
Get to see it in my face it's my excited face I can see it a lot you can't contain him like
It's an incredible thing to be a part I am late to the game but
It is amazing to be a part of something. That is so
Beloved all over the world and to pick out one thing that's been the most incredible part is impossible
It's pretty great though. When you get to hang out with some kids and when you see kids react to these characters in these movies
It's a nice it's a nice reminder of what's the power that it actually has and what's important the Marvel Cinematic Universe is a diverse
World how important is it for you guys to play strong female characters in that. Um, I you know, it's
honestly, my character has had such an interesting journey because I started out in Iron Man 2 as
Basically like a glorified secretary
Who like kicks ass on the side and then you know
We've got to really like kind of peel back the layers of an act and build an actual person
um, you know, not just like the sexy secretary the sidekick type of
You know played out version of you know
Someone so it's it really as the kind of 10 years has passed. You know, it's it's amazing to see how
important it's been for
You know all these different Studios to catch up with like what's going on in the real
We're all then what's going on in the zeitgeist and what's important to you?
to fans and audience members and really it's the it's the
audience that and the fans that have pushed
the studio's like Marvel to
you know to
you know come into this century and
You know and to really show
The characters that represent what's going on in the in this world?
And so it's it's really awesome to be to feel a part of that, you know
Uh, yeah, I mean it was it was really cool
I when I sat down with Ryan and he talked to me about this character Okoye, I mean what was really exciting to me?
I've always been passionate about telling stories from an African female perspective and showing their
Complexity as well as their strength and and and their abilities and their capabilities and so to hear what he had in mind
Was just really thrilling because it was a character
I I just knew I had never seen before
the idea that she was the head of an army and the head of the security of this nation and
that the sort of Pat I felt an immediate connection to that in the sense that
you know having grown up on the continent like the idea of this sort of nation was really exciting to me one that had never
been colonized and so the idea of protecting it it was something I connected to really quickly and and so it was it was
really cool because I got to the beauty of that like what scarlet saying is is
We got to really collaborate and myself and the other women that we were creating these characters with
with Marvel with Ryan in the course of creating Black Panther and and we really got to collaborate on on our mindsets around how these
Women would would address the world and how they would be, you know
complicated and and powerful and they're in a country that allows that unabashedly brings the women into the fold as
full capable equal equal members of whatever part of society they are great at being a part of so I just loved being able to
Be a part of that sort of a narrative and yeah
Absolutely
It was about time to see that sort of thing as a whole across every single genre
you know storytelling and so it's really exciting but that's happening so much, you know with uh,
You know with Scarlett's character and and of course
Brie, Larson's character and you're just seeing it in so many ways throughout things now and that's really exciting
Well, you guys are both great custodians
In that message two quick questions one for each of you Scarlett, you've played Black Widow many many many
What's your favorite part about playing her?
um, I think my favorite part about playing Black Widow is that she's
not afraid to be
Vulnerable. She really that's one of her strengths. I think is that she you know, she's
She doesn't always know how she's gonna do something. She just knows she's gonna do it and she doesn't always feel
capable she just she's just gonna try me I'm and and you know do her best and that's that's
you know that's good enough for her as her best and I think she's you know someone who is a very
fully realized
woman and and she's grown and she's learned through her losses and she's kind of
Abdun flow with the change and I I like that about her. I like that. She's okay being
broken, she's okay, you know coming from where she's come from and she's she's okay with you know having
Having these kind of shades of grey in her past, you know, I think she's really um
She's she's complicated and she's she's okay with that. I think that's cool. And third time's the charm. Uh,
You know, she's very unapologetic and
She's not really trying to please her anybody. She really answers to something much deeper
that's you know really rooted in her for mothers and her forefathers have created a system that she believes she must maintain so
there's something really thrilling about playing a woman who who is
Unapologetic in what she can bring to the table and in her strengths in in how she can strategize around a situation
And and still at the same time, you know has a ferocity and and is very at ease with her femininity
You